hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the feed hs olympiad that was
played online in 2020 and this is one of
the games that i think
should win the brilliant surprise fida
contacted uh me alongside some some
other
uh chess streamers and youtubers and
said that we should make a list of our
top three games for the
uh for the brilliancy prize and i
published my list on twitter yesterday
and this is the game that i think
uh well is the nicest one for the uh
brilliancy prize so this is the the most
awe-inspiring
inspiring game uh but you can also be
the judge of that so
uh without further ado let's check it
out it's italian grand master daniel
divierny
uh versus uh alexis shirov it's no
wonder that uh a game uh well maybe
qualified that uh that may win the
brilliancy prize
uh involves alexa shirov uh but we
should see what actually happens in the
game so without further ado uh let's
check it out so uh the vietnamese with
the white pieces opens with d4
ah sorry about that and we have d5 by
shiroff
uh c4 and c6 so we have the slav defense
we have knight to f3 and knight to f6
and it's going to be
quite quite a long main line of the slav
with e3
bishop to f5 and knight to c3 now black
finishes the
at the development of the of the cage
while the bishop is out of the cage
knights to h4 going after the bishop and
bishop to e4
f3 uh you know uh pushing the bishop
around the bishop back to g6 and the
queen b3 now going after the b7 pawn so
all standard stuff
queen to c7 shear of defense the pawn
and now bishop to b2 white says that he
is ready to castle queenside
bishop to e7 and knight captures on g6
now we have h captures and a queen side
castle
uh sheriff continues development we have
knight beat to d7
and now we have a trade and d5 captures
captures
and as the king is still on c1 rook to
see it is probably coming
uh we have a nice prophylactic move from
white king to b1
we have a6 preparing to continue
pushing on the queen side with b5 and
now rook to c1
and here there are three games that
reach this exact same position and in
all then queen to b6 was played offering
a queen trade
however in this game i should have goes
queen to b8 and this is a new move so
already as of move 14 we have a
completely new game and now
that vietnamese is on his own uh to
crack the position
uh so what happens now we have h4
preparing at
uh uh development on the king side with
with the g4 h5 probably should have will
castle kingside as he wants to bring
this rook into the attack as well so you
you
you should be ready and h4 uh gets ready
for that we have b5 now shiro starts
pushing on the queen side and
a four now basically offers a queen
trade
if captures then you can just trade off
the queens pick up the pawn
and everything will be fine for white uh
however [ __ ] of castles here and now he
says
okay you can even grab my pawn here but
we have castles of opposite side so
grabbing a pawn on the side that your
opponent wants to attack you
isn't really the the greatest way to go
about it for example
if you go after the pawn uh it looks
nice looks like it's playable but rook
a6 then the queen moves the other row
comes to a8 and you
you will have problems on the queen side
definitely
so here at virginia decides let's close
the position on the queen side
and let's shift the attention of the
game on the king side as
that's where i want to attack so rook
the c8
shirov does get his rook into the game
and bishop to d3 now continuing uh
to develop pieces g4 h5 is incoming
and the shiro of course a great attacker
himself knows that this is uh coming so
he blocks the g
pawn with his queen queen g3 while also
threatening to
uh to just uh pick up the base of the
pawn chain so roxy the g1 defending and
now uh well uh shirov kept the queens on
the board for a reason he wants to
attack uh but
where is his attack that's the question
here he makes the attack
sort of happen by playing rook to c4 and
now he's preparing the other rook to
come to the c file he wants to play b4
bust open the
uh the queen side and enjoy a very nice
attack and if you capture
uh the the rook then d captures or b
captures can be played uh
it's hard to say what should have had in
mind if d captures uh
first 92 attacking black queen as well
and after the queen returns now
uh the white queen moves somewhere or
even rook to c1 can be played
all in all it's a very tricky position
uh of course engine will hold this with
white and even probably a human in a
classical game
uh but uh in rapid game and especially
against an attacker like alexa shiro you
do not want to play white in this
position
so after look the c4 we have f4 by white
uh here the the the sneakiest way for
white to
continue his attack is actually h5 and
then after pawn captures now you kick
away the queen make room for the g
pawn and after the queen moves now g4
and now white's attack is happening a
little bit faster
uh but uh divinity goes for f4 instead
and now rook a to c8 should have just
continues piling up on the c
file we have queen to d1 now controlling
the g4 square so rook h3 might be played
they're forcing a queen trait here
and now shiro continues with b4 a very
sneaky idea here with rook captures on
d4
now if white captures then you do get to
capture this with
check for example captures captures
would check uh however
white uh of course doesn't have to
capture white can play knight e2 and now
you have problems as now the queen and
the rook are under attack
this was possible a move ago i forgot to
mention this
while the queen was still here instead
of rook 8 to c8 there was the option of
going rook captures on d4
and now for example if knight to e2 you
have the in between rook
captures on d3 attacking white queen but
you still have to give up the exchange
and
now you move the queen and uh well it is
a nice position to play with black
but okay like we said shirov decided to
do this maybe afterwards so first he
brings another attacker into the game
queen d1 and now like we said this no
longer works
uh but now b4 uh continuing the attack
the knight has to move
we have knight to e2 uh here rook to h3
is also very nice
trying to trying to get uh a queen trade
in for example queen g4 you can trade
the queens captures captures
and now you play bishop captures and um
knight captures on g4 and now bishop
captures on c4
grabbing that rook d captures and now
you move the knight and now again
white is very comfortable here black has
a very nice pawns here and
the game continues with white being up
the exchange however
vernee doesn't like that he first goes
knight to e2
attacks the queen gets the knight out of
harm's way queen to g4
and now knight the c1 so the knight is
out of harm's way
the rook is hanging the queen trade is
being offered and here
you could do a lot of things so you
could capture the
uh capture the queen you could maybe
move the rook you could do a lot of
things
but you could also do the move that
alexis should have played so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the move sheet of plate here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
incredible
knight the e4 uh and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
uh this is the move that she have played
so uh offering a full queen
uh and if the queen is captured then or
all hell just breaks loose for example
if queen captures and g4
then you capture on d2 with the knight
of course this comes with
check and now it doesn't matter what you
do yeah if king get to a2 then you just
allow this
instant b3 with check and now it doesn't
matter what you play if knight captures
then rook to a4 is checkmate and if you
don't capture if you just go back
you could go here then just rook to a4
check
yet again the knight has to block and
now rook captures an a2 is checkmate
so this is what would happen if the
queen sacrifice was accepted so of
course he doesn't accept the queen
sacrifice
he tries something else capturing the
knight is actually the safest way to go
about this just captures
capture it and now the queen is really
undefended so here shiro would have to
trade
uh you capture on e4 and the game
continues here with with black having a
lot of pressure on the queen side
but white should be okay however after
this knights the e4 move we have bishop
to e2
just attacking shirof's queen shiro now
plays queen to f5
threatens a lot of nasty discoveries
here as the queen and king are on the
same diagonal
bishop back to d3 now blocking the nasty
discoveries and now shirov just
continues like nothing is hanging knight
d to f6 and indeed nothing is hanging
here you really have to be
careful what do you do here uh there are
a couple of moves you could do knight to
b3 the safest way
to go about things uh as you really want
to defend this
bishop on d2 however here g4 was played
as it's nicely defended twice by the
rook
and by the queen but now uh it's
actually shiro again who is winning so
feel free to pause the video
and win the game for sure of while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
exact same queen
sacrifice again and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
knight captures on g4 you just
eliminated this uh
pawn and now white really doesn't have a
good way of continuing
the game because he just blundered upon
and there's no good good continuation
however dvirni uh persisted with his
idea he played rook characters on g4
probably expecting knight captures with
czech queen captures and then just the
queen captures rook but shiro of course
played queen captures on g4
and now white runs into the exact same
uh
queen sacrifice because you can't move
the queen otherwise you hang the bishop
with
check and there's not much you can do
here so dwinni accepted the queen
sacrifice but now
knight captures on d2 with check and
again if king a2 then b3 check
king a1 rook a4 check everything is
happening nicely rook captures with
checkmate the knight covers the b1
square
so of course after knight captures on d2
check king a1 was played
but now uh king day one was played but
now the problem is that
only one rook is guarding the knight so
it's even faster rook captures with
check
and it was in this position on move 29
that daniel
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
uh of course if you move the king you're
getting checkmated if you accept
a trade once you're also getting
checkmated again if bishop to b1 then
just row captures with
check king a2 and b3 is checkmate and
if you don't if you play king to a2 then
just b3 is checkmate on the spot as the
bishop covers the a3 square so you don't
have an escape route here
so after rook captures on c1 vienna
resigns and
what what a game and what a victory with
the black pieces for alexis shirov
now uh it wasn't easy going through you
know millions of games deciding which
game to
uh get my choice for the brilliancy
prize that of course is a joke affiliate
sent me some
15 games that you know caught their
attention to choose from as uh you know
most of the games are just positional
snooze fests
uh so it wouldn't make sense to go
through all of them uh but
uh very happy that they you know
narrowed down the list and that i was
able to
to choose from like 15 of them but yeah
this is the one i i thought was the most
interesting one if you guys like we
could also show my choice too and my
choice three
uh but yeah that's basically the game i
do hope you enjoyed it and i think today
or tomorrow affiliate will announce uh
who they uh
choose for the which game they choose
for the brilliancy prize and maybe it
will be this one maybe it will be some
other game uh either way we're gonna
show the one they
choose as well uh so yeah uh once again
i do hope you enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank grant mcgregor stephen jaffe
mario fabri evolving schmidt and nick
vitolo for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
stuff
a saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your friday